let's start today with a very meaty
substantial discussion about the
American economy inflation has reached
its lowest annual level in two years and
the right is coming up with new ways to
talk about how the economy is absolutely
terrible and that's the question we're
going to address with real numbers today
I recently reported to you on on Monday
in fact Monday of this week or three
months ago I don't remember no it was
two days ago I told you about the better
than expected jobs numbers that came out
of April during the Biden Administration
and I hesitate to give too much credit
or blame on these issues in general to
presidents because they have to do with
so many broader macroeconomic Trends but
everybody wants to make everything
political but let's not get ahead of
ourselves let's start with inflation and
then we'll move on from there consumer
prices in April rise at slowest annual
rate in two years reminder
often when we see the inflation numbers
from last month they are actually the
numbers for the 12-month period ending
last month so in may we get the April 22
to April 23 numbers in June we will get
the May 22 to May 23 numbers this is
like a trailing 12-month period consumer
prices in April this is uh Yahoo finance
consumer prices in April April showed
inflation pressures remain elevated
while headline Prices rose at the
slowest annual rate since the period
ending April 2021. according to the
latest data from the Bureau of Labor
Statistics the Consumer Price Index
revealed headline and inflation Rose 0.4
percent over the last month and 4.9
percent over the prior year in April Now
reminder inflation has been very high as
you can see here this is a chart uh
dating back to 1970 we had this period
uh culminating in uh June of 2022 where
inflation got very high uh as high as
it's been going all the way back to the
early 80s and then exactly as predicted
uncontroversially it has been declining
declining declining my prediction was
and there's nothing special about me I'm
not patting myself on the back I'm not
special in any way just the way things
were looking getting an Outlook of what
we were seeing uh you know in the used
car market in the grocery store in real
estate just looking a little bit being
reasonable adults most of us some
children in the audience my sense was by
the end of this year
we would be somewhere in the low fives
mid fours roughly when it comes to
inflation which is still historically a
little high but dramatically lower half
of where we uh reached so that's
happening and of course you will you're
already seeing right Wingers saying
David these numbers are obviously fake
have you seen the price of eggs lately
and of course it's not just driven by
the price of eggs this is a a measure
that we've talked about a number of
times it's composed of a number of
factors but let's now ask a broader
question if we look at all of those
different indicators that I often tell
you about to answer the question is the
economy doing well by traditional
measures which don't capture every
aspect of the economy but they give us a
picture what's going on with inflation
how is GDP where is unemployment how's
consumer confidence how's the stock
market doing what about trade balance
you get a picture that is quite
unremarkable in the sense of things are
pretty much okay
now does that mean we don't have
inequality no we do and we've had it for
a long time does this mean wages haven't
been keeping up with inflation
absolutely uh going back well beyond Joe
Biden but the picture is not a very
scary picture you look at GDP GDP in Q4
of 2022 was up 2.6 percent and in q1 of
this year was up 1.1 percent 1.1 percent
again this is annualized this isn't an
incredible number we look for two to
three percent but it's not a bad number
either we saw of course this is a chart
going back that includes the pandemic Q2
of 2020 we saw one of the largest GDP
decreases uh in in a very long time we
made a lot of that back in Q3 and then
the numbers have just sort of been like
okay at the beginning of 2022 we
actually saw some negative GDP growth
then more positive in Q3 and Q4 of last
year and then now a positive but not
explosively exciting number so GDP is
sort of like okay
you look at the unemployment rate and
you see of course this big spike here
this was the the heart of covid of the
pandemic and since then unemployment has
declined decline declined much of this
under President Joe Biden how much
credit we give him depends on who you
are but be that as it is you see that
the unemployment rate has now gotten
very low as low as it got under Trump as
low as it's been quite frankly dating
all the way back to the late 1960s so
unemployment is very low
huh doesn't look like a disaster we then
look at consumer confidence consumer
confidence is another indicator
representing the confidence of the
average person in the American economy
and you see that uh consumer confidence
did decline a little bit in April not
much but a little bit
um but it is historically at quite a
high level consumer confidence is a
little bit below where it was at the
height of the stock market rally while
Trump was president but it is
historically quite high and you the the
chart is on the screen and sort of the
numbers speak for themselves well what
about the stock market these are S P 500
returns going all the way back to 1930
as you can see this very clearly shows
the boom bust cycle of the American
economy and as you can see here we had
um 2022 last year a very bad year for
the stock market it 2021 was quite good
that was again a year under Joe Biden
the s p returning 27 percent in 2021
losing 19 in 2022 and so far this year
the S P 500 has returned more than seven
percent and it's only May so really no
major red flag big scary data from the
stock market either things are pretty
okay and then lastly you look at the
trade balance which many uh folks on the
right often like to discuss important to
understand so trade balance means how
much are we exporting versus how much
are we importing the US has had
consistent trade deficits for a long
time this chart uh let's see if we can
go back further
um there we go so if you go back to the
mid 70s the U.S has had high trade
deficits and this is because we import a
bunch of oil and consumer products and
consumer products more recently oil has
not been the source of the trade deficit
that applies under Trump and Biden even
though Trump likes to pretend that it
was only under Trump that we weren't uh
having a deficit on oil but it's under
Biden as well and as you can see if we
look more recently since early 2022 the
trade deficit has been declining so
again a situation that is much bigger
than Biden but nothing hugely concerning
so what is the big picture with the
economy the big picture with the economy
is that stepping outside of the
political realm without assigning credit
or blame to Joe Biden or Kamala Harris
or Donald Trump or Mike Pence we just
take a 20-year View and we look at what
happened under Trump and what's been
happening on under Biden and it is
really difficult to make the statistical
case that we are in a disastrous economy
today could a major recession be coming
of course that's a reality of the type
of capitalist economy in which we live
that was true under Bush Obama Trump and
Biden but are we in a disastrously
perilous place right now that we can
point to when it comes to any of these
indicators the answer is no